Dominic Raab who's being investigated
for bullying is passing judgment on
Nadeem zahawi who's just had a one
million pounds fine for not paying his
taxes on time and that pretty much
epitomizes this conservative cabinet
when the Prime Minister came into office
he said that he would run a government
that would have honesty integrity and
professionalism at its heart none of
those three things are happening today
last year Nadeem zahawi said that there
was nothing to see when it came to his
tax Affairs he wrote letters to or his
lawyers wrote letters to people saying
that they should cease and desist in
talking about his tax Affairs and the
Prime Minister this week said that
Nadeem zahari had been Charis it's
transparent when he hasn't actually
answered a single question about his tax
Affairs now this matters because a few
months ago he was Chancellor of the
exchecker you may forget because there
were four of them last year but he was
Chancellor of the exchecker in in
responsible for Britain's tax Affairs
and tax collection the taxes that we now
find that he wasn't so Keen to pay
himself so if the Prime Minister wants
to stick by his commitment for integrity
honesty and professionalism he should do
the right thing and Sack Nadeem zahawi